miss me
moving to New York City was the best
thing you ever did Jesse if you hadn't
rebelled against your father and left
that dreary military base in Texas you
never would have met the Ross children
sure you had bigger plans for yourself
and you first stepped foot in the Big
Apple but becoming their nanny was one
of the most rewarding jobs of all time
you connected with Emma Luke Ravi and
Zuri because you knew how it felt to
have absent parents and you showed them
what the true meaning of family was all
about that's what love is like stretches
over any distance there's no doubt about
it
Disney's Jessie is one of the best TV
series of the last decade but like most
shows it has dozens of mistakes from
things that just didn't make sense to
continuity errors to everything in
between keep watching to find out which
Ross sibling curiously stayed the same
age throughout the series four year run
if there's one thing every TV show has
in common its mistakes that flew under
the filming crews radar most of the time
producers and directors aren't even
aware of these mistakes until viewers
later point them out and this is exactly
what happened in season 1 episode 2 of
Jessie the episode titled the talented
mr. Kipling has not one not two but
three mistakes we're about to unveil the
first one but stay tuned as we'll reveal
the other two at the end of this video
in this episode Jessie finds out that a
woman living in their building has a
problem with mr. Kipling pit it is
before picture of a pair of boots and a
matching she wants him banned from the
building ASAP but despite being scared
of the seven-foot lizard Jessie does her
best to hold on to the family pet but
there's a mistake in the elevator scene
of this episode at first we see Jessie
Luke Emma and Ravi get into the elevator
but in the next scene when the elevator
doors open Zuri is standing front row
and center but she wasn't in the
elevator when the doors closed just
moments before when we're watching an
episode of Jessie it can be hard to
remember that it's events aren't
happening in real time the actors of the
show don't film the scene in a linear
sequence which can make recreate
every little detail all the more
challenging in season 1 episode 21 Emma
and Zuri asked Jessie if they can watch
an educational movie and she gives them
permission but what Jessie doesn't know
is that the girls are pulling a fast one
on her they use the educational movie
spin as a decoy when really they're
watching a scary doll movie in the
episode titled a dolls outhouse there's
a huge mistake that somehow managed to
make it on to the TV show and that
happens when the girls are watching the
scary movie and Jessie walks in
prompting them to change the channel at
first we can clearly see that Emma and
Zuri are eating popcorn from a bucket
the bucket is half full and some of its
kernels even jump out when Emma gets
scared but moments later Zuri get so
frightened she puts the bucket of
popcorn over her head and not one kernel
falls out it's as if the bucket is
suddenly empty when it was half-full
just seconds ago
[Music]
most TV mistakes occur in episodes but
this general error takes place in the
opening theme song of Jessie at the end
of the catchy tune we see Jessie strut
out of the elevator and meet up with the
rest of the cast outdoors it's a blink
and you'll miss it moment but Jesse's
head passes right through the doorway of
the elevator she looks super tall in
this shot which isn't very accurate
according to home study a residential
elevator can be anywhere between 6 feet
and 8 inches to 8 feet tall and while
Jessie is a fan of wearing high heels
she's really not that tall in real life
[Music]
sure she might look super tall when
standing next to the kid she babysits
but debby Ryan's the actor who plays her
is only 5 foot 6 in real life so it just
doesn't make sense that she would be
taller than an elevator door this
animation mistake caught the eye of
detail-oriented viewers tell us if you
noticed this mistake in the comments one
of the most amazing things to ever
happen on Jessie took place in the
episode titled from the white house to
our house it's in this episode that
Michelle Obama is welcomed onto the
Disney Channel set but that didn't stop
producers from making a handful of
mistakes during this episode in season 3
episode 13 Emma puts together a pep
rally for her school and Ravi is
determined to become the school's new
mascot problem is Luke competes against
his brother for the gig because well if
he wins he'll get to hang out with the
cheerleaders cheerleader is gonna be my
honey a few goofs happen during the pep
rally scene and these mainly revolve
around the applause meter when Ravi
starts rapping the applause meter starts
moving problem is no one in the crowd is
clapping one second the applause meter
is stuck on getting warm and then when
the camera zooms out again it's on hot
viewers pointed out that while Luke
received more applause the meter stated
that Ravi had received more applause
than Luke you may have charisma but I
was born to look goofy in public here
are the things we love talking about old
Disney Channel shows like Jessie if you
have a soft spot for all things Disney
and Nickelodeon be sure to subscribe to
the things and
don't forget to click that Bell and turn
on post notifications so you never miss
another video if you're watching on your
phone or tablet be sure to go into your
YouTube settings and switch on
notifications this way you can be the
first to comment on our latest videos
the pilot episode of Jessie is titled
New york-new nanny and at least the
foundation for the rest of the series
but some of its statements were proved
incorrect by the time the second season
of Jessie made it onto the small screen
it's perfectly normal for pilot episodes
tab continuity errors in them especially
when writers write the pilot episode
before giving the rest of the series
much thought in New york-new nanny
Jessie tells the cab driver soon my dad
who's in the Marine Corps practically
blew his flattop when I told him I was
moving to New York but in season 2
episode 26 it's revealed that her dad is
a lieutenant colonel in the Army
this mistake went unnoticed by viewers
who don't have a military background
however seeing as Jessie was raised in a
military setting it's unlikely that she
would get her father's job title wrong
but that's exactly what happens in the
episode titled GI Jesse the writers of
the show originally intended for JW
Prescott to be in the Marine Corps only
to place him in an entirely different
military branch and it didn't go
unnoticed you talk in a foxhole the
enemy's likely to find you and take you
out in season 4 episode 14 we find out
that the Ross siblings are excited to
attend the win big shindig Suri reveals
that it's her first boy-girl dance
[Music]
and asks Emma for some advice but the
episode titled dance dance resolution is
flawed from the get-go in the opening
scene Jessie pours the kids some orange
juice and sets the pitcher back down on
the table and then something very
mysterious starts happening the pitcher
starts to displace itself between tapes
without anyone ever moving it on top of
that the amount of orange juice in the
pitcher also varies between tanks
clearly the scene wasn't filmed
continuously and producers had a hard
time keeping track of just the pitchers
juice levels these mistakes are easy to
miss considering how hilarious the
opening scene is but once you notice it
you just can't unsee it that's two major
goofs take place in season 1 episode 3
and they're so extreme that they'll have
you wondering how producers miss them in
the first place in the episode titled
used karma Jessie and the kids learn
about Karma and how it can come back to
haunt you so Luke attempts to wash the
karma off of him by standing out in the
rain and cleansing himself when Bertram
first sees Luke his hair is completely
dry and his clothes are wet but not
soaking but then when Bertram walks
through the window to close the blinds
on Luke Luke's hair is completely
drenched and his clothes are dripping
another mistake happens at the end of
the episode when Bertram scares Jessie
and the kids while wearing a cloak he
sits on the couch and reaches over to
grab the remote but then out of nowhere
mr. Kipling can be seen watching TV on
the side table but the coffee table had
been bared just seconds ago I can record
him fish both new york new nanny and a
doll's outhouse are filled with
inconsistencies that can easily be
spotted in retrospect and one of these
continuity errors revolves around Ravi
Ross Ravi spent most of his life in an
orphanage before being adopted by the
Rosses and it's revealed that he had
just been adopted a month before the
pilot episode aired so it makes perfect
sense that Ravi would take his time to
adjust to his new life before attending
school in a dog's outhouse
that he has just been allowed to attend
school for the very first time problem
is this statement is disproved in the
pilot episode of the series in new york
new nanny we see jessie escorting the
kids to the lobby they run out the front
door when their school bus sounds its
horn and it's here that we can clearly
see Ravi waiting for the school bus with
the rest of his siblings so evidently
Ravi had been to school before the
events of a doll's outhouse took place
we mentioned earlier on that there were
a total of three mistakes in the episode
titled the talented mr. Kipling we've
already covered the first one so now
let's find out about the other two oddly
enough these mistakes happen in the very
same scene in this episode Luke and Emma
are paired up together for a photography
assignment and Luke uses his camera to
spy on Bertram who is in his bedroom
shaving his back the first thing viewers
noticed was that Luke's camera isn't
real
this is made obvious by the fact that
the camera doesn't actually have a
screen the second mistake is a
continuity error which is later revealed
in the episode titled the kid whisperer
in this episode Bertram is stunned to
find out that his bedroom has a window
turns out Bertram didn't know he had a
window because of all the clutter on his
windowsill but wait how could Luke have
seen Bertram shaving his back through
the bedroom window if the window had
been overrun by clutter my room doesn't
even have a window we love Emma Ross but
there's something strange about her
interviewee displaying signs of sarcasm
might be a red flag and mainly it's the
fact that she doesn't seem to age like
the other characters do in Jessie emma
is said to be 15 years old for the
majority of the season and her age
doesn't change even though for Christmas
episodes are aired throughout the series
four year run by the end of Jessie emma
is said to be about 17 years old but
then in the spin-off series bunk'd which
takes place after the events of jessie
emma is only 16 years old just marker o
to show the tattoo artists what I want
and that's a wrap on the 10 huge
mistakes that made it into Disney's
Jesse before you go tell us which Jesse
scene made you laugh the most and why in
the comments section below give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to the things we'll catch
you next time thanks for watching
[Music]